all right welcome everybody we we have a
real real mess of a situation now some
of you might still actually be watching
the debate it's still in its last
minutes we did get shut down and got a
copyright strike over on twitch and
what's incredible and we're gonna have
coverage of this actually tomorrow is
that CBS the host of tonight's debate
has actually hired a very high-priced
political consulting firm to do the
takedowns of independent media covering
the debate the organization is called
praxis political legal and we are going
to absolutely go in on them tomorrow
this is an organization that has been
hired by CBS for the sole purpose of
targeting channels like ours and we are
going to do a post show here as the
debate is is wrapping up right now if
anybody has a recommendation we're sort
but this is only on YouTube and Facebook
you only on YouTube actually because we
are we are banned on Twitter for 24
hours if anybody has any suggestions as
to a live stream that you would like me
to pick up so while we talk we have
something to look at in terms of what's
going on um let me know what YouTube
livestream I should pick up if there's
like a spin room stream or something
like that that is not likely to cause a
takedown but an incredible incredible
situation
CBS hiring expensive political
consultants to take me down to take me
down if you can imagine so we are going
to get momentarily here to your comments
and maybe we will open up the phone
lines if we end up getting getting to
the 50 new members I have a few to add
we are I am already in consultation with
an attorney about this and this is it to
call it a [ __ ] show is is an
understatement for sure so we will be
talking about that a lot on tomorrow's
program if anybody has a suggestion
about some some stream they would like
me to pick up if there's going to be any
kind of like a you know spin room stream
or something like that
I am glad to find that of course we
don't want to do the CBS one since we
are we are liable to get shut down
I thought the debate was by and large a
disaster I'm curious to see what you
guys thought it
it had you know it ended up having a mix
of the entertainment value and the
policy discussion value and I feel like
I got very little out of the debate
actually it was a lot of the same stuff
and then in the end did not really learn
anything new on policy Bloomberg was
better prepared for sure the crowd from
what I'm reading was a what was a was a
sort of staged crowd where you were able
to buy your way into the crowd which is
which is absolutely incredible we're
gonna look at some of Donald Trump's
tweets here's we are going to look at
Super chats let me before we go further
there were some people who signed up on
my website join pakman.com right as we
were getting banned so let me say thank
you to them Laura sterling is new member
number 24 tonight
Samantha Arnold is new member number 25
tonight Sasha
price bath is new member number 26
tonight and then Justin coos Nair is new
member number 27 tonight so welcome to
everybody who is coming in from having
watched the debate our stream was shut
down on Twitch we are banned from twitch
for 24 hours and I'm gonna have a lot of
information tomorrow about exactly what
went down and who got us banned and a
whole bunch of other stuff if you have
questions for me submit them via super
chat they will show up over in that gray
window and in fact there are already
some that are coming in and I'm going to
get to them momentarily I would love to
find some kind of spin room stream but I
am NOT able to find one right now and
let's see I'm trying to see over on
YouTube I tried to find some kind of
live let's see debate spin room let's
see if we can find anything here this is
all old stuff so I'm not actually seeing
anything I am in my pajamas for people
who are wondering yes of course I'm in
my pajamas yeah I'm not seeing any
obvious livestream that's going on right
now
that we could grab I would be curious
about what's going on there but I'm just
not seeing anything debate spin room
live maybe that will show us something
no this is all this is all old stuff if
I go let's see if on the youtube
homepage a lot of stuff that has nothing
to do with what we're doing here but uh
yeah I'm not seeing that some people I
saw streamed the entire thing on YouTube
and did not get shut down which is
unbelievable no so we're not going but
let's see what's happening over with our
friends to actually TYT may may actually
have Content ID so that may be risky as
well no we're not we're not going to CBS
because CBS is who shut us down so we're
not gonna do that that's that's the
whole reason that we're here my friends
so we are we are certainly not doing
that let me do one Refresh of spin room
live see if we find anything if not
we'll leave it I have plenty of other
things that we can look at and that that
we can certainly discuss yeah I'm not
finding anything
ABC live oh filters let's see can I
filter for live oh here we go let's see
what we've got
spin room could this be something let's
take a look at what this is this is all
very ragtag
I have no clue what we're watching this
seems to be one person with a camera in
the spin room but I guess we'll leave it
right I mean why not let me get into
questions because I see that questions
are coming in fast and furious here
gregory shavers jr. says dumb question
can't you stream from your website yeah
but we'd have no audience no super chat
function no interactive function very
few people visit my website compared to
to our 800,000 YouTube subscribers pair
Taryn hey pear great to see you I saw
your membership just renewed pear is a
big supporter from Sweden pear says the
small part I saw it was complete chaos
with all shouting over each other then I
like I then luckily I fall asleep yeah I
did not think that this was a
particularly good debate I don't predict
that the polls are drastically going to
move that's my senses of right now other
questions coming in copper sealed says
do you think the debate impaired Bernie
you know I rarely have felt after a
debate that Bernie Sanders might lose
support because the crowd was so stacked
against him I actually wouldn't be
surprised if Bernie lost a point or two
nationally although I don't know that
it'll have significant implications in
terms of his state by state support and
possibility of winning thanks to Terry /
jests for the beta level subscription
Kevin al to Lou
thank you for the super chat which drugs
do you do none I don't I don't really I
don't really do drugs Joseph said to
Gotti says on a scale from one to ten
how based are you 11
for sure max says how is it okay that
the debate isn't free in public I
completely agree with you these debates
are helping us figure out who we are
going to support in a primary or in a
general election the idea that they are
for-profit and controlled by one network
at the exclusion of everybody else is
absolutely and completely bonkers and it
should not be allowed and the DNC should
enforce that but of course they don't
they don't let's see the blue Nobel says
the
biased debate against Bernie by far yes
yeah it was just a mess of attack Bernie
attack Bernie attack Bernie often Bernie
gets no chance to respond half the time
Bernie does get an opportunity to
respond my assessment was that he wasn't
even really responding and was often
going into something else I thought it
was an absolute mess and basically the
difference I saw from last debate to
this debate is Bloomberg was better
prepared for the predictable attacks
against him and I don't think I really
learned much about policy whatsoever
let's see he's a lion dog says Ziya net
cleek is a new member you know I don't
see that I don't see that name showing
up at join pakman.com let me see here I
am NOT yeah I'm not seeing that but we
do have a coupon code available if you
so we got shut down by twitch tonight
CBS hired a high-priced political
consultant named let me give you the
exact name of this organization we're
gonna we're gonna talk about them
tomorrow on the show Praxis political
legal CBS wasn't even shutting us down
themselves they hired consultants to do
it and we are now banned on twitch for
24 hours if we get one more strike there
twitches bye-bye so we are of course
going to appeal on fair use grounds and
it is an absolute and total mess but if
you want to support the streams go to
join pakman.com our target tonight is 50
new members 50 new members we are more
than halfway there I will thank
everybody and the coupon code 20/20 now
will save you 66 percent a rich ropa
thak says what is up with the Red Line
trains being so late couldn't tell you
having been haven't been on the red line
for a long time and haven't haven't
ridden it for a while and couldn't tell
you what's going on with it
Sam here says facebook stream with three
views on personal page got striked on
yours i assume you mean that's
incredible Jason W says if Bernie gets a
majority which is more likely the DNC
change
the rules or will Bloomberg run third
party um I I don't actually think Bernie
will end up with a majority before the
convention so I don't know that I think
if Bernie ends up with 50% plus one
it'll be at the convention not before it
but we'll have a better sense of that
after after Super Tuesday so we'll talk
more in detail about that then
Christopher hatch says the Thom Hartmann
show okay rich chase says outside of the
debates if the Democratic Party can
change the rules to let Bloomberg into
the debates can't they change the rules
about super-delegates of course of
course and we have a couple of reports
including one from Politico that that is
exactly what they are thinking of doing
you're just joining us let me know in
the chat who you believe won the debate
now I don't mean who do you plan to
support I know a lot of times we get
biased and whoever we support we think
won but who do you believe won the
debate in terms of moving the needle to
grow their support I don't know that
anybody did other then and I'm not
supporting him Michael Bloomberg
imploded at the last debate and his
public support didn't go down as you can
see here we've had two polls after the
last debate and Bloomberg's polling 13
and 19 that's basically where he was at
the beginning before last week's debate
so my question is did anyone actually do
anything to grow their support during
tonight's debate let's see here Peter
King says why isn't Bernie making an
argument against Biden how he lost both
Senate and House when he was VP so
frustrating you know I don't actually
know that that's a good argument to make
because it's very common that when the
White House changed his party one year
in the following midterm two years later
that party loses control of either or
both the House or Senate historically
that's very common so I don't know that
it's really a very strong argument to be
making so I don't know that it's a great
thing for Bernie to be talking about
Ryan Anderson says does homogeny affect
the success of Scandinavia I don't
believe so I've addressed that in detail
on my
YouTube channel check that out Ricky
Williams says Amy's education education
plan screw your needs wants and dreams
younger generation
I'll subsidize you to learn a low paying
job to wait on me in retirement I don't
know that it's quite so horrible but
it's not the plan that I would
necessarily say is is my favorite of the
ones that we saw today welcome if you're
just joining us it's been it's been sort
of a sad night we in order to what do
what we thought would protect us from
copyright strikes we did the live debate
only on Twitch and we got banned and so
now we are back here we've got live
video of the spin room we have no clue
we are the I found a stream and I am the
only person watching this stream I have
no clue what this is it's someone who's
down there at the at the debate spin
room according to what YouTube is
telling me I'm the only person watching
this debate but it is interesting
because we might actually get some
interesting spin room stuff as people
start to enter the the spin room area
very very unusual let's see if we can
hear anything
Wow well anyway uh we much appreciate
what what we are seeing here I want to
say thanks to Matthew Hall
Matthew is new member number 28 this
evening at join pakman.com I really
appreciate your support we will open the
phone lines wide open if we get to 50
new members we are almost 60% of the way
there and you can get a two-thirds
discount 66% off with the coupon code
2020 now let's see here oh there are
super chats I want to make sure I don't
miss any Resaca says voting for Bernie
but I think Biden won this one more
energy than anyone best audience
reaction well audience reaction from
what I read in order to get a guaranteed
seat tonight you had to pay a bunch of
money so the audience I think was a
skewed audience but Biden did have more
energy than he's had in just about any
recent debate let me say thank you to G
Barrett herb IDE for the YouTube
subscription sabrina's a far from here
in Boston says huge Bernie fan but I
worry Mike Bloomberg may have a point
with a statement regarding the long-term
impact of Bernie versus Trump on the
courts other offices going red what are
your thoughts I I actually I'm telling
you I don't think blue Bloomberg wasn't
hurt by his first performance tonight's
was better Bloomberg may gain support
between now and Super Tuesday I'm not
supporting for the guy I'm not
supporting the guy I'm not campaigning
for the guys what I what I meant to say
but I believe Sabrina that he probably
made an okay enough impression to stay
level gained a little bit of support and
pick up a not insignificant number of
Delegates on Super Tuesday Michael Smith
says David Pakman flat plus Anthony
Fantan o EP when I am ready to do a
collaboration with Fantan o or anybody
else on the Left who wants to do a
musical collaboration I am ready to play
drums I've got my electronic drum set
all set up I'm getting the last things I
need to record directly into my laptop
audio and video I can do it I can do it
and I'm ready whenever whenever
other people are ready let me say thank
you to Steve Koenig Steve Koenig is new
member number twenty nine this evening
at join pakman.com thanks Steve I so
appreciate your support on this debate
night casiano Battaglia says do you
believe Bernie will use Medicare for all
like Trump uses the wall even if he
didn't get it people will still rally
for it I totally believe it is doable
well you know I have to be careful
whenever I say that Medicare for all
will be much tougher to make a reality
than some believe I'm called a defeatist
but I I don't believe that bernie is
dishonest like Trump so no I don't think
Bernie will start propagandizing around
Medicare for all the way Trump just says
hey we're we built the wall we're
building the wall III don't see Bernie
doing that no Kevin all tular oops
scrolled up hold on Kevin all tiller
says David I was in your foreign policy
101 class why did you draw boobies on my
paper instead of grading it I did not
teach any foreign policy classes so it
couldn't have been me woke nation says
why didn't Bernie just say I am three
for three with my ideas I'm I'm
wondering which three you're thinking of
Kevin de Loup says Biden looked so pale
and couldn't talk straight Biden had
some struggles but I do think it was one
of Biden's best performances so far he
has he was higher energy than he's been
in a long time
other than the last debate and I think
Biden did okay and he'll probably do
quite well in South Carolina is my
prediction captain Rama says sound from
crowd was cut audibly for Bernie and
Pete I didn't notice that in the moment
but in my earpiece it might just not be
loud enough to be able to see here those
nuances I'll go back and listen to it
dusty Dark Horse says considering the
rapid acceleration of broadband internet
and Pocket supercomputers
how much does precedent matter anymore I
don't know in which area you're thinking
of in terms of precedent but certainly
broadband internet and supercomputers in
our pockets are changing things for sure
Landen at Saverio says most americans
won't see that it this way but I think
Bernie had a strong foreign policy night
Israel Palestine fending off red Bader's
and reminding all of our serious
missteps on the world stage do you agree
I think Bernie did fine on foreign
policy you know I've said before I don't
find foreign policy to be Bernie's
strength and I do think he had a fine
night on foreign policy where he didn't
come off as not knowledgeable the way he
did particularly in 2016 let's see here
lift solace says did Bernie really
compare Daniel Ortega to Lincoln I
missed that part I think that happened
right when we were in the middle of
getting our streams shut down Adam
Waddington says if by told if Biden came
off is more angry than energetic to me
yeah me I mean you know I am so deep
into this stuff that it's hard for me to
tell how a general audience will
perceive it I saw Biden as energetic and
angry but maybe you would see it more as
angry maybe an average crowd would would
see it that way that that's certainly
possible let me say thank you to Jeff
Fisher who is new member number 30 on my
website tonight join pakman.com is the
place to get a membership almost
instantly almost with very basic
computer skills you can get a membership
in in under a minute
I would say and if we do get to 50 new
members I'll open those phone lines up
and hear from some folks let's see other
super chats barely alive sessions thanks
for the YouTube subscription Junie
McGraw says hey David I didn't get a
chance to watch the debate is it worth
the watch or was it garbage like I've
been hearing the entertainment value of
this debate was a seven the
informational value was about a three
and a half so if you know who you're
voting for I don't know that I would go
back and watch the entire debate I don't
any hard Guil away hos that if T
Harville says do you think Warren is
done we have seen stranger things happen
in the past so I
not ready to say that Warren is done but
we will know by midnight on Tuesday
whether Warren is done effectively let's
see what's going on with Tom Steyer here
in the spin room is your question for
you yes sir first question is about that
attack
you know Joe Biden had aim towards you
when he asked you about that and then
I'll give you a second question look
that was something that happened 15
years ago I came to the conclusion that
we should never have private prisons ice
older than I've worked against it for 15
years
you know I we bet I've moved on I've
worked for racial justice for 15 years I
started a bank specifically to support
businesses owned by black people Latinos
and women
I've worked actually to get rid of
private prisons from my home state and
they're not used I've worked to end the
kind of harsh mandatory sentencing that
actually Joe Biden's been in favor of he
wrote the climate the crime bill for
goodness sake to put hundreds of
thousands of black men latino men in
prison so look this is something that's
15 years ago that I corrected by myself
when I had no political ambitions
whatsoever because I was doing the right
thing and that's what I've done in my
whole life I've made a mistake I've
admitted I've not only corrected it I've
worked seems genuine to me beyond that
and that's what I've done you I want to
ask you also second question I wanted to
ask you also about you know billionaires
in their race in a new if so snoozy poll
that came out I said 54% of Democrats
believe that billionaire is funding
their own campaigns has a negative
impact on the Democrat
look every four years what I've done is
try and deal with the biggest problems
in America I went after climate change
when no one else would do it I'm
probably I've worked on it for over it I
know a lot of people laugh at steyr he
strikes me as totally genuine like when
he had the Bernie fanboy moment it was
totally genuine when he had it I he just
seems honest to me you can disagree that
he's qualified you can disagree with his
policies you can say Bernie's better on
health care or someone else's better on
climate whatever but I don't find Biden
steyr rather to be overly rehearsed I
don't find him to be calculating I don't
find him to be dishonest those are the
things that I would say about him I'm
not supporting him but I would support
him over a bunch of the people on the
stage to be perfectly honest let's
continue with Super chats Chris cannon
says my bad about the lost bet oh yeah
it was a bet about my pajamas anyway we
won't we won't go back to that now
Kesten Klepper says miss the debate was
Bloomberg attacked again shouldn't the
race come down to who his best fit to
survive being memed by Trump
electability is an issue oftentimes
electability is also correlated with who
gets the most delegates Bloomberg was
attacked again but he was better
prepared he's certainly I mean listen
he's not the most dynamic retaliate er
but he was better prepared and he
probably is not going to lose any
support after this debate because he
didn't lose any support after the last
debate Van a Dulles says cheers thank
you I appreciate that
Cody says they met he won three of three
states with his ideas fair I
misunderstood the super chat team OS
says I already early voted for Bernie
here in Texas but I felt like he went on
rambles and tangents tonight I agree I
thought he was not directly answering a
lot of the questions I think both women
candidates spoke well did you see mayor
Pete chased out of a fight for $15 a
fight for 15 March I did not see that
but I will indeed look it up let me say
a huge two-channel bernie a huge thank
you to John Koster who is new member
number 31 tonight Brandon Salazar is
remember number 32 tonight and Alexander
debayer is new member number 33 tonight
the bar is filling up on route 250 you
can sign up very easily at join
pakman.com let me just listen to a
little bit more of Tom Styer Reagan pipe
dream that is not gonna happen that's
why we have a government housing is at
the center of inequality in this country
and there's a huge racial aspect to it
as well
so unless the government steps in and
builds those units they're not gonna get
built and we're gonna have the kind of
problem that we have in North Charleston
and in fact you know I started a bank
specifically to help black people
Latinos and women who are being
discriminated against by the banks and
financial service companies of the world
and in fact we are I would do that I
would push that courage so repeating
some of the same answers he gave the
first journalist
let's see christian gordon says why does
Bernie have to keep explaining his
Medicare plan is the money there or not
the money is there if we want it to be
there I believe it will cost more than
Bernie says to deliver the level of care
that I would like to see but I do
believe it can be done the way Bernie
describes this is going to be a big
fight no matter who is the Democratic
nominee if any of these Democrats
becomes president all of their health
care plans will be subject to debate and
argument in terms of affordability that
will be the case with Bernie's plan but
it's going to be the case with everybody
Obama couldn't get a public option right
Biden wants a public option if Biden's
the next president he'll have to fight
and argue about funding the public
option there's going to be a fight no
matter what I want to get health care to
everybody that is good and there are a
number of different ways to do that
Medicare for all is one very good way I
simply do believe it will cost more then
some folks are willing to entertain at
this point in time
Kyle Flynn says how can I get a Pat
Forde but pick oh I don't know that's
that that would be very very pricey
we'd have to verify funds availability
that because that would be very pricey
Bowery Boy but no Bauer boy says switch
to mixer it's better than twitch there's
an idea
Shane errs says the misconception
question was a standard named a weakness
job interview question to display
humility a self oh and self-awareness
none of them landed yeah Joe Biden
saying he has more hair than people
think or than he thinks Elizabeth Warren
thinks she eats more than people think
she it was very very weird and those
questions I find them to be really
annoying I don't think we learned
anything part of it is how does the
candidate respond do they even respond
like a remotely normal person very few
of them did tonight
dusty dark horse says Stiers father was
a prosecutor in the Nuremberg trials if
that's true that is fascinating
looks like there we see Bernie heading
somewhere unclear exactly where this is
live spin room video coming to us
oh there's Elizabeth Warren working her
way somewhere looks like she's going to
be interviewed we will watch that from
behind
Blee Mayo says if Bernie cheat I vite
Trump okay she's lyin dog says
Corrections I Annette cleek is not a new
member she tried to join on twitch as it
was shut down thanks okay thank you for
the update I appreciate that
rich chase says me again while being the
other nominees punching bag
I believe he fended them off well do you
agree hot tea would go well with the
pajamas yeah I'm not really wearing
pajamas but listen I think Bernie was
very very heavily attacked tonight and
it was known going I mean we knew going
in it was going to happen I think in
some instances Bernie fended it off well
I think in others Bernie sort of went on
tangents that did not really relate that
much to what was actually being
discussed and that is certainly a
problem oh I think this is Fez Shakira
I'm in touch with him by email and
here's Bernie shaking some hands let's
see what we got
when you win the popular vote and I won
you win the New Hampshire primary guess
what people go after you I got that I
think at the end of the day there is a
reason why we are beating Trump in poll
after poll after poll here's our ear a
bit amusing friend of mine right here is
Bernie's deputy campaign manager look at
our in in Pennsylvania and I think that
that reason is that the working people
understand that we cannot continue to
have a government that works for the
wealthy and the powerful they want a
government that represents all of us so
I feel pretty good you mentioned your
name was booked a lot on yes it was were
you ready for that were you expecting
that Cornyn yes I was
look again when you win the first three
oh look at army right in there people
are gonna go after but it's you know
always painful is that in a debate for
Mac you just don't have the time the
moderators try to do it you've got 45
seconds to respond you really can for
example I am very proud of my record
hard blankets came up eyes President
Biden really got yeah well I'm proud of
the fact I got a d-minus voting record
from the NRA I'm proud of the fact that
30 years ago not not yesterday 30 years
ago I supported a ban on assault weapons
and that's my view right now so people
want to hear more of Bernie or do you
want me to keep answering super chat
questions what do we want to do well not
the NRA but what does disturb me I have
to say in these debates
is sometimes while all of the questions
are good and important we sometimes
don't get to the most important issue
and that is how does it happen than in
the richest country in the history of
the world we are the only major country
not to guarantee health care all
we don't have paid family and medical
leave we got 500,000 people sleeping out
on the streets tonight after giving a
trillion dollars in tax breaks to the
top 1% and large corporations how does
that happen and it happens because in
America today
you have a billionaire class that has
incredible economic and political power
I know that's something the corporate
media doesn't like to talk about
certainly we don't talk about hurting
congressmen but in the last three years
Michael
Merve himself has seen his wealth
increased by fifteen billion dollars and
yet half of our people are living
paycheck to paycheck like that is an
issue that we didn't talk about in this
debate the last debate the debate before
that is an issue we have to do something
about a moment that we saw where it
seemed like you were almost arguing with
the crowd or debating with the crowd
that about okay that's an interesting
question do you know much money your
course to get a ticket yes envelope how
much I read that it cost seven hundred
and seventeen hundred and fifty dollars
so to get a ticket to the debate you
have to be fairly wealthy most working
people that I know don't spend seventeen
hundred dollars to get a ticket to a
debate and that's problematic but you
know people yeah that's what the DNC did
but at the end of the day I felt very
good about the debate because I think
you know my opponents raised a whole lot
of issues and I think we were able to to
fight back effectively I'm still
standing and I'm looking forward to the
South Carolina primary on Saturday and
Super Tuesday on two things one thing
that mayor Pete brought up that you
didn't get to address directly he said
how can you lead a revolution when
you're not willing to lead a change in
the filibuster rule I'm paraphrasing
there but I want to give you the
opportunity to look I hear is a promise
that I make for all of the major
legislation that I want to see past
criminal justice reform ending absurdity
of having more people in jail than any
other country legalizing marijuana or
passing Medicare for all long
immigration reform we will do that with
50 votes plus the Vice President of the
United States we use the Budget
Reconciliation act we could use other
Senate budget a Senate rules to do that
but in terms of the filibuster here's
the problem if you get rid of the
filibuster tomorrow then the United
States Senate becomes like the House of
and I think the founding fathers of this
country were not stupid and they said
good we're gonna create the house
majority rules in the Senate it's gonna
be a little bit different and I think
that that's okay I think in the Senate
you want people to stand up they want to
filibuster they want to get up and talk
three to nine hours they have I did that
they have a right to do that but at the
end of the day on all of the important
legislation that I am campaigning like
we're not gonna wait for 60 votes we
will pass it with a majority plus device
but some of you you mentioned you would
consider moving the embassy back to
where it was why why bring that up why
would you push to no spot not bring that
up but why would you consider removal
well I think what you want to do is
embassy location is a symbolic statement
and what I'm saying is that has to be
looked at within the context of the
United States doing everything it can
aid to protect the independence and
security of Israel but also plainly
providing justice to the Palestinian
people you got youth unemployment in
Gaza something like 70% people cannot
even leave Gaza
despite the miserable living conditions
there and I want in my foreign policy
will be to say to the Israelis to save
the Palestinians you know what we're
gonna start working this stuff out but
it cannot just be a one-sided policy
pro-israel it has to consider the pain
and the suffering of the Palestinian
people as well anything happened on that
favor stop your momentum I think we did
just fine and I think the issues that
we're talking about raising that minimum
wage to a living wage 15 bucks an hour
making sure that every kid in this
country has the opportunity to go to
college regardless of income demanding
that the wealthiest peoples country stop
paying their fair share of taxes I think
that's an agenda supported by the
American people I think it's gonna get
us past the
all right very interesting listen if
anybody can get ahold of whoever ones
this stream it's just a channel on
YouTube called News Update as you can
see here only five people are watching
this if this is someone who might be at
future events and I would love to
promote whoever this is just put a
camera in there and let us see what's
going on I absolutely love this this is
an amazing public media service I have
no clue who this is I hope it's not some
vile racist or anything like that I just
have no clue who it is only five people
are watching this stream and it's
phenomenal so if anybody can can figure
out who this is and get them in touch
with me or whatever I I would absolutely
love it I'll just give you a you know
show you what it is that's going on here
so people can see looks like the
username is News Update official videos
news update official videos
I'm loving it absolutely absolutely
loving it let me say thank you to a
couple of other people who just signed
up Ricky Gonzales is new member number
34 tonight MOA guy een or gain is new
member number 35 tonight Jennifer
Douglas Runnels is new member number 36
very much appreciate your support you
can grab a membership at join pakman.com
let's see here
other super chats let me make sure I
don't miss any we did riches okay Eamonn
min-ji's says David do you think there
would be a place for steyr in a
hypothetical Burnie Administration maybe
I mean I think aspire is a smart guy and
he's the type of left businessperson
that genuinely might be interesting to
have on involved in some way shape or
form if you've got to have a billionaire
I don't know that stires the worst guy
to have involved quirky quips says if
Pete were president do you think
countries who whip or kill gays can have
a good relationship 1,700 more than my
income yeah that would be an interesting
thing to see that that would be an
interesting thing to see I don't know
what it would be like I mean listen we
have relationships with lots of
countries that do things that are
personally offensive to some of our
leaders would it be different with Pete
being gay and countries that for example
stone gays I don't know I don't know the
answer David Adams says you skipped mice
her chat I didn't see it I thought it
was odd that CBS said one more
commercial break and then just said bye
did you know so it was it was they were
probably supposed to go to that break
without saying that it was over to keep
people to get traffic to those few
commercials and then to just say thanks
for joining us goodbye it's a common
common tactic you do an intro and then
you go immediately to commercial and you
got a big crowd that you carry over or
you're kind of the show is over
a lot of sitcoms the show is basically
over and it looks like it's a commercial
and it's like 56 past the hour and then
at 59 past the hour they come back after
you've watched three minutes of
commercials and go right to credits or
like show you know a blooper with
credits over it it's just the strategy
to get people to watch - to watch
commercials that's all it is let's see
other Super chats Milan davit cava says
thoughts on Bernie's overthrowing
countries I missed that moment because
that was when I was dealing with the
twitch strike and shutdown so I don't
want to comment on the piece I didn't
see Adrienne benningfield says David
when are we gonna see you playing pacman
on Twitch as a show fundraiser
well I'm banned on twitch right now for
bringing you the stream tonight my so
listen my twitch direct messages are
exploding right now because we were
taken down tonight on Twitch by an
organization called let me give you the
exact name praxis political legal even
though the debate was on CBS
a lot of streamers you would all
probably know are telling me this is a
company that was created just weeks ago
it's a brand new company these could be
potentially specifically targeting
channels unable to afford to just start
suing people or legal representation
man you have guys have no idea what is
in my Twitter DM z-- right now it is
absolutely and totally crazy and Wow
hopefully tomorrow I can give you more
information about what went down tonight
but we were we were shut down
very very hard brutally very strongly I
think it's the way I would say it we're
in the spin room here and we don't know
who this person is
I see people telling this streamer that
we want to contact them about what
they're doing and if they're going to be
I don't know providing live
live-streaming at other political events
we are okay let me answer a few more
Super chats here Resaca says Bernie
should have mentioned Bloomberg is in
Epstein's book I wondered if that would
come up but it doesn't seem like Bernie
to to jump into that type of thing and
enjoy cool panda says what's your
opinion of Pete's claim that Bernie's
more radical since Bernie's Medicare
takes away private insurance whereas
what's in Europe doesn't it's still not
clear to me that Bernie would ban
private insurance I think it would just
not be that great so very few people
would want it but I still I still I
thought that it was made clear that
Bernie would not ban private insurance
but we can't seem to finalize that bit
of data
Edwyn Vega has subscribed on YouTube
Joseph Scheuermann says what are your
thoughts on tying the minimum wage to
inflation the market the cost of living
could help us avoid a repeating cycle of
raising the minimum yeah I don't know
that the market makes sense because then
if the market goes down minimum wage
goes down that's not good
cost of living varies significantly even
within states nevermind from state to
state so I think if you're going to tie
it to something it should probably
probably be inflation let me say I'll
also say thank you now to Todd burger
Todd burger is new member number 37 we
are just 13 members away from getting to
our goal of 50 i if you appreciate these
streams and we are now into hundreds of
hours of 20/20 election streams consider
just grabbing a membership at join
pakman.com it's quick its painless it's
cheap and you can save 66% as it says up
there with the coupon code 2020 now if
you want to do something to support
the stream that's free hit the subscribe
button we are only a hundred subscribers
from actually 99 from eight hundred and
nine thousand we are just 99 subscribers
that means if just three percent of the
people watching hit the subscribe button
right now we will roll over to eight
hundred and nine thousand and of course
make sure that you like the stream likes
are always appreciated
comments are appreciated subscriptions
are the most appreciated
we'll see if we hear from any other
candidate in the spin room coming up
here we are live in the spin room we've
heard from Tom Steyer so far we've heard
from Bernie Sanders we saw Elizabeth
Warren show up to be interviewed and we
will see if we are able to hear from
anybody else other super chats coming in
Joe Kay says likely coronavirus vaccine
is made from American biotech companies
top scientists innovation driven by
profit socializing the economy will lose
US ground that's an interesting question
what is the incentive if it is not
financial to develop a vaccine if you
are a private company I mean listen just
because you get rid of private insurance
doesn't mean you get rid of
pharmaceutical companies you still have
pharmaceutical companies they might just
make a little bit less if the government
is negotiating I mean I'm thinking out
loud here it doesn't really seem like
the end of the world and you're doing a
good thing you are stopping what is
potentially a pandemic that we are now
dealing with let me say thank you to
Denis Lacroix Denis Lacroix is new
member number 38 today thanks very much
I appreciate that subscription other
super chats coming in quirky quips
says New Zealand and the US are the only
two countries that allow pharmaceutical
ads on TV yes we know money we know and
for TV ads if they stop medications go
way down do you think ants down you
think and answer I'm sorry I am having a
really hard time understand
the question but we know that
advertising specific drugs on TV gets
people to go in and ask their doctor
about them and it sells more drugs and I
don't I don't believe that they should
be allowed and I've said that before
David Adams says it was odd / funny when
Bloomberg claimed that he killed it at
the last debate I found that it's I
guess he was maybe making fun of me if
it was self-deprecating if he knows how
poorly he did at the last debate and he
was making fun of himself
I appreciate the effort although it sort
of fell flat if he was serious it was
just very weird I don't I don't know
what to make of it
blue dream cush 23 says didn't the
audience applause for Bloomberg seem odd
to you even going as far as booing
Bernie twice maybe planted of course it
to get a guaranteed seat at the debate
you could you could be in like a
giveaway you might get a seat you might
not there are reports that they get a
guaranteed seat it was over $1700 it's
not mostly Bernie supporters that can
afford 1750 for a seat at the debate
that's for sure
jill jones has grabbed a youtube
membership Captain Crunch has grabbed a
youtube membership thank you so much I
do appreciate that let me say a big
thank you to tyler Darcy who is new
member number 39 tonight and let me say
thank you to Patrick Haynes who is new
member number 40 tonight very much
appreciate your support
also want to say thank you to Ruby
Darden Ruby Darden is new member number
41 tonight fear in the chat let me know
who you believe won tonight's debate try
to separate yourself from who you plan
to support or who you already voted for
depending on what state you're in and
think about who is likely to get a
polling boost from tonight's debate
that's really what I'm interested in I
think maybe Biden gets a little boost
because he finally did show up with some
energy
I think Bloomberg maybe gets a boost in
addition to all the spending on ads that
he's been doing
we'll see what the results are probably
by Monday we will have new polling that
is post-debate
Ryan nawicki says in what way do you
think the establishment would fight
progressive values after Bernie wins a
presidency assuming he wins well the
thing you have to understand and I know
that a lot of a lot of people don't like
to hear this there are a lot of current
Democrats don't even control the Senate
and a lot of the Democrats in the Senate
don't agree with all of Bernie's
policies a lot of Democratic senators
never mind Republicans don't agree with
Medicare for all so it's there's not
going to be half the the establishment
won't have to do anything new to fight
Bernie per se because you already have
the establishment controlling such a
significant part of the Democratic Party
as it is if that makes sense we may hear
from additional candidates in the spin
room we were just let's see what the
audio sounds like here
all right I guess not very much is
happening right now so I'll keep
answering questions Daniel Molina says
why talk specifically about what a plan
costs if it's going to change during
negotiations every why talk about
anything if it's going to change during
negotiations I mean if all of these
things are subject to negotiation you
you still outline the way you see it
right now that that still makes sense to
me sin one Manson thank you for the
super chat Bauer Boyce says what are the
chances that bloomberg purchased the
audience I don't think I mean listen he
didn't need to
it cost 1750 to get a guaranteed seat he
could just say to his supporters hey
it's really important that you be in the
crowd go and buy a seat I don't think he
necessarily needs to buy the audience an
H says keep it up thanks Ann Junie
McGraw says not sure if anyone brought
this up but did you watch John Oliver's
take on Medicare for all it was
educational and reminded me of your
takes I have not seen it a bunch of
people emailed it to me and I plan to
watch it when I have a moment let me
also say thanks to hecqs seven one three
four the YouTube subscription let me say
thank you to Stefan Giz lacin gisla Sanh
I hope I'm saying that correctly Stefan
is new member number 42 this evening
very much appreciate your support
Stefan also want to say thank you to
David foz dar
that was weird new member number 43 is
David Foster I don't know why my uh that
that weird image went up on the street
I was very odd let's see Pete Buddha
edge is here let's see if we can hear
anything from him I gotta give a lame
for senator
take take it up bring her on
people just leaving without answering
questions apparently others Elizabeth
Warren
check out this guy with this cool
microphone am i right okay I was going
around doesn't seem like there's too too
much more there necessarily for us other
super chats Andrew F says hashtag Boomer
burg PS a good place to eat in Boston oh
boy there's so many good places let's
see what are some places I like in
Boston in in Cambridge I like Mama's
Jewish delicatessen excellent excellent
spot to restaurants that I like Sarma
and Olli on a great sort of
Mediterranean tapas what else Michaels
deli in Brookline great totally
different style Jewish deli if you go in
there
say hi to Steve who runs it and tell him
David Pakman sent you the number of
people that have gone in and to
Michael's deli in Coolidge Corner and
announced their fandom of the David
Pakman show it's got to be at least four
what other places are good there's a
great spot also in Brookline called the
Bess's cafe it's a little family-run I
it might be I believe it's some regional
Chinese food I don't remember what
region exactly but it's a really great
spot what are my other favorite spots in
Jamaica Plain
JP seafood cafe is great
Brassica kitchen is a good spot what
else
I don't know I'm having trouble thinking
of many others but there's so many good
spots so many good spots in Boston don't
let anybody tell you there's no good
restaurants in Boston other super chats
shiso lion dog says did klobuchar Buddha
jej or Warren do anything tonight to
survive beyond Super Tuesday we won't
know until Super Tuesday it's it's
conceivable that Clovis char and Warren
did enough to get enough delegates in
some states on Tuesday that they can
justify continuing but we may see them
very quickly exit it's it's unclear to
me at this point
Robin Marshall says Canucks saluting
your coverage and insights dumb you
get heat for streaming debates should
not be on commercial channels as it is
debates not for revenue couldn't agree
more
Tokyo Meg Tokyo megaplex says Pete
Buddha jej says the Russians want chaos
yet he causes the most chaos in the
debate by interrupting is he paid by the
Russians I don't I don't think that he
is I don't believe this but it there was
a lot of interrupting let me say thank
you to our mondo solace Armando solace
is new member number 44 of the evening
Thank You Armando for the support
I very much appreciate it I also want to
say thank you to the real life channel
for the $5 super chat no question or
comment included with it but very much
appreciated nonetheless let's see if we
can hear it seems like Elizabeth Warren
is being interviewed let's see if we can
hear anything
we really can't that's what we've
determined is that we really can't hear
a damn thing other than microphone guy
here every once in a while whispering
into his microphone I wish I knew who
was streaming this I really do i I don't
we just stumbled upon this stream from
the spin room and it's not bad I wish it
was pointed in a more interesting
direction it seems that people are
trying to get word to this person that
we re running their stream so if
somebody can get word to them to maybe
point the camera towards something a
little more interesting I would love it
and if we could get some audio from
wherever Elizabeth Warren is being
interviewed that would be great imagine
if we could actually direct the camera
that would actually be stunning but for
whatever reason this is the angle that
that we currently have and we don't
really know too too much about what is
what is going on otherwise other than
one candidate at a time filing in and
being interviewed Saturday February 29th
will be the South Carolina primary and
then Tuesday one week from tonight will
be Super Tuesday we will be streaming
live and bringing you results as they
come in it's gonna be a big big night I
was thinking of starting at 7:00 but I
actually think it probably makes more
sense to start at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
on Super Tuesday because it might go
quite late so we'll see we'll see but
certainly a big stream plan for Super
Tuesday on Tuesday March 3rd and my
prediction is that we will have a very
good sense by midnight on to the next
Tuesday night of who has zero shot left
and should drop out and whether the most
likely scenario is nobody getting to 50%
plus one delegate or Bernie getting to
50% plus one delegate I think those are
the two most likely scenarios obviously
5:38 estimate agrees with that about a
40% chance of each of those scenarios
epic fails says via super chat was it me
or did someone yell out
yeah yell get out to Clovis char if that
happened I didn't hear him if that
happened I did not hear and I didn't
it's possible it happened during the
chaos of getting banned by twitch I
don't know let me say a big thank you to
Carlos Soto Gil who is new member number
45 of the evening and as the clock is
striking 11:00 p.m. here on the East
Coast that is going to do it for our
coverage today a lot of chaos at which
ban which I will tell you more about
tomorrow thanks to everybody who joined
some piece of tonight's stream and we
will be back with